foreign
I just expect him to be the same as he's
always been and not really do much for
our country uh nothing really I don't I
don't think he's a good leader
we have to watch out what we're spending
to help support Ukraine actually do
something about inflation and not go
I think he should be focusing on the
wall there's just so many people coming
into this country and I am for anyone
coming into this country legally but the
way they are just running over our
border is not right I just think that
like it's just gonna be even worse than
it already is like inflation is already
so bad inflation has to be won it
whether it's gas prices or the price of
groceries and secondly crime we're at
all-time highs and we're we're not we
are not as a nation taking it as
seriously as we need to we're not
punishing those who are hurting good
people yeah we need to lock down and put
a hard clamp on crime I hope that we can
get the economy
better I think the past like three or so
years it's kind of spiraled downhill and
I hope that his team can
get it
back up to where it used to be
I don't know that I really see that
I think I would love for women to be
treated like human beings and have our
bodily a Time